>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Well good afternoon and welcome.
I am Francisco Macias from
the Law Library of Congress.
We have certainly had the pleasure
of delivering a robust slate
of events in observance of
Hispanic Heritage Month.
These programs are possible
because of the collegial spirit
that fills this wonderful
institution.
And for that I want to
thank all my colleagues,
many of whom are present
here, for the commitment
in making 2016 another successful
celebration of our heritage.
Today's program, A Spanish
Reading of Hemingway,
brings to us an unorthodox
reading of one
of America's most celebrated
authors.
We ask that you be prepared to
see Ernest Hemingway certainly
through the lens of World War I.
But we also ask that you set
aside some of what you know of him
so that you might see him through
the lenses of Cuba and Spain,
spaces from which he drew his
inspiration, and through authors
like Miguel de Unamuno,
Miguel de Cervantes Saavedra,
Felix Lope de Vega y Carpio,
Pedro Calderon de la Barca,
Rafael Alberti, and
Vicente Blasco Ibanez.
Douglas LaPrade is Professor
of English at the University
of Texas Rio Grande Valley.
He has received two
Fulbright grants to Spain.
Over the course of eight
years, while in Spain,
he taught at the University
of Barcelona.
He has published four books in
Spain at the University of Salamanca
and at the University of Valencia.
His book are based on the censorship
of documents from the Franco regime
that he found in the official
archives of the Spanish government.
In Spain he is a member of the
Board of the [foreign words].
This foundation is named for
Hemingway's Spanish biographer.
In Cuba, he is a member of
the [foreign word] Hemingway.
His work has been reviewed
in Spain's leading newspaper,
El Pais , and in Cuba's
official newspaper, Granma .
In addition to his work
in South Texas he lectures
in Spain and in Cuba.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Douglas LaPrade.
[ Applause ]
Thank you Francisco.
You're a national treasure
and our ambassador-at-large
to the Hispanic world.
And I thank you.
It's always a pleasure to talk
about Anglo-Hispanic
crosscurrents with you.
It's been a pleasure and
thank you for arranging this.
The title of this lecture is "A
Spanish Reading of Hemingway."
But this is not the first time
there has been a Spanish reading
of Hemingway in Washington,
D.C. Seventy-four years ago there
was an important Spanish reader
of Hemingway's works.
That Spanish reader was the
Ambassador of Spain in Washington.
When the Spanish Ambassador read
Hemingway's works at the Embassy
of Spain in 1942, he
was not pleased.
The Ambassador had just received
a letter from the Counsel of Spain
in California who warned him
that a Hollywood studio was
preparing a film version
of For Whom the Bell
Tolls , Hemingway's novel
about the Spanish Civil War.
In his letter to Spain's Ambassador
the Counsel condemns Hemingway
as follows.
"Given the subject of this work,
and taking into account the
leftist tendency of this author,
this film could, if completed,
become anti-Spanish propaganda
that is highly detrimental to
our government's objectives."
A week later the Ambassador of
Spain responded to his Counsel
in California with a
letter that read as follows.
"Regarding the film, for
Whom the Bell Tolls ,
which Paramount Studio
intends to produce and which,
as you judge correctly, could
serve as propaganda against Spain,
I think it would be advisable
to insist upon halting
production of the film."
Upon receiving this letter from
his Ambassador the Counsel of Spain
in California approaches
Paramount Studio in Hollywood
to request a copy of the script.
Paramount Studio cooperates with the
Spanish diplomats and provides them
with a copy of the script.
After reading the script the
Counsel writes the following letter
to the Ambassador of Spain.
"The script is atrocious, a
thousand times worse than the book.
The Red Bandits described by
Hemingway appear as angels,
moderate Republicans with
a high democratic ideal.
On the other hand, the nationalists,
who are always called Fascists,
appear as loathsome sorts with no
honor or courage who are devoted
to cutting women's hair
off after raping them
and killing their aged parents.
I see no way how this script
could be made even half decent,
no matter how much it
is changed or modified."
When the Ambassador of
Spain receives this quickie
from his Counsel in California, the
Ambassador in turn writes a letter
to Spain's Minister of
Foreign Affairs in Madrid.
In this letter from the Ambassador
to the Minister dated September
25th, 1942, the subject line reads,
"Report on Paramount's
Proposed Film Against Spain."
In the first sentence of the letter
the Ambassador expounds as follow.
"Paramount Studios in Hollywood
has plans to produce a film based
on the book published by the writer
Hemingway entitled For Whom the
Bell Tolls , which was written
for the propaganda of
the Reds in Spain."
The next month, on October 7th,
1942, the Ambassador of Spain
in Washington writes another letter
to the U.S. Undersecretary of State.
The letter says, "The film script
based on Hemingway's book is, quote,
'completely insidious
for the Spanish nation
and it is almost impossible
to fix it,'" end of quote.
The letter continues to
issue the following warning
to the American government.
Again, quote.
"The Embassy of Spain in
Washington has thought it necessary
to make these points clear
and to engage the cooperation
of the authorities of the United
States to determine the possibility
of halting the propaganda
which by all accounts is unfair
and inaccurate, and
which could contribute
to complicating the current
relations between Spain
and the United States,"
end of quote.
Let's stop here and re-examine
the title of this lecture,
"A Spanish Reading of Hemingway."
These diplomatic letters tell us
that the first Spanish reading
of Hemingway in Washington,
D.C. occurred 74 years ago
when Spain's Ambassador tried
to stop a Hollywood studio
from making the movie version
of For Whom the Bell Tolls .
This happened in 1942
when America was involved
in the Second World War.
American troops were
fighting against Hitler
and Mousseline while back home
in California an American film
studio allowed a Fascist official
to censor a copy of an
American film script.
The American public became aware of
this because articles were published
in the San Francisco Chronicle
about Paramount's complicity
with Franco's censor.
In spite of the protests
of the Spanish government,
the film was released in 1943.
The film stars Gary
Cooper and Ingrid Bergman.
However, some of the Spanish
Counsel's recommendations were
incorporated into the script.
In the movie, the Fascists
are called nationalists.
The Spanish officials were very
proud of this semantic victory
in the propaganda war, the war of
words that accompanies all wars.
So when we talk about a Spanish
reading of Hemingway in Washington,
D.C. we must realize that a
Spanish reading of Hemingway
in 1942 has influenced the way
Americans perceive Hemingway.
The Spanish readers altered
the English language script
of the movie version of
For Whom the Bell Tolls .
In 1942 the citizens of Spain could
not even read For Whom the Bell
Tolls because Franco censored
the novel entirely until 1968.
However, the diplomatic
correspondence we have just examined
proves that Hemingway's
name was well-known
to the highest government
officials in Spain.
Some of the letters we have cited
reached the desk of Spain's Minister
of Foreign Affairs in Madrid.
This is the counterpart to
the U.S. Secretary of State.
We must ask ourselves, how many
times in history has a writer
or artist been considered a threat
to the national security
of a country?
As we have seen, the agents
of Franco's Spain all label
Hemingway a red propagandist.
Americans can debate Hemingway's
political sympathies endlessly.
Was he communist or
just a sympathizer?
However, to Franco's
Fascist regime in Spain,
Hemingway was clearly
an agent of propaganda
at the service of the reds.
Hemingway's role in the Spanish
Civil War was well-known to Franco,
and for that reason Franco
censored Hemingway's books published
in Spain.
For example, in one of
Hemingway's short stories
about the Spanish Civil
War entitled,
The Old Man at the Bridge ,
Franco's censors changed the
word "fascists" to "troops."
Once again, Franco's sensitivity
of semantics is apparent.
In another short story about Madrid
entitled, Capital of the World ,
the censors eliminated the dialog
in which one character says that the
"bulls and the priests are
the two curses of Spain."
Another line of dialog from
this censored passage speaks
of the necessity of killing the
priests and the [foreign words].
Hemingway's novel entitled,
Across the River
and into the Trees includes
a phrase critical of Franco.
Specifically, Hemingway calls
Franco "General Fat Ass Franco."
Of course, Franco's censors
eliminated this phrase
entirely [laughter].
As we celebrate Hispanic
Heritage Month here at the Library
of Congress we should recall
that October 12th is the
national holiday of Spain.
October 12th has been called El Dia
de la Hispanidad, when Spain wanted
to emphasize its connection to its
former colonies in Latin America.
For others, October 12th is Columbus
Day of the Day of the Virgin
of the Pilar, the Patroness
of Spain.
October 12th also is important
in the academic calendar
at universities in Spain.
Historically, classes begin
at the Spanish universities
after October 12th.
Eighty years ago this week,
on October 12th, 1936,
a famous ceremony took place
at Spain's oldest university,
the University of Salamanca.
The famous philosopher Miguel
de Unamuno was President
of the University of Salamanca
and he presided over the ceremony
on Spain's National Holiday.
The Spanish Civil War had
begun three months before
on July 18th 1936, and Unamuno had
to conduct the ceremony with some
of Franco's Fascist
officers in attendance.
One of Franco's generals,
Jose [foreign words],
stood up during the ceremony
and shouted, "Viva la muerte.
[Speaking in foreign
language]," or long live death.
Death to intelligence.
Unamuno responded by giving an
impassioned defense of culture
which he felt was imperiled
by Fascism.
Unamuno knew that Franco's side
would win the war and he said,
"[Speaking in foreign language]"
or rather you will conquer
or you will not convince.
Franco's wife escorted
Unamuno from the hall.
Unamuno was placed under
house arrest and died
of a broken heart two-and-a-half
months later on New Year's Eve.
Hemingway even wrote a short
story as a homage to Unamuno.
Actually, he published this story
three years before the Spanish
Civil War.
The story's entitled A Clean
Well-Lighted Place which takes
place in a bar in Spain.
Unamuno was an agnostic philosopher
in addition to being President
of the University of Salamanca.
Unamuno's seminal essay is
entitled The Tragic Sense of Life,"
of Del [speaking in foreign
language] de la Vida ,
published in 1912.
Unamuno says that "IT The tragedy
of life is not the prospect of death
or hell, but rather the
uncertainty of knowing whether
or not there is anything
in which to believe."
The word "nada" becomes a virtual
refrain in Unamuno's essay.
Nada is the Spanish
word for nothing.
The word "nada" occurs
about 150 times in his essay
as Unamuno wonders whether
or not there is a god
or if there's just nothing.
In Hemingway's story, A
Clean Well-Lighted Place ,
an old man drinks alone in
the same bar every night
until well after midnight.
An older waiter is sympathetic
to his customer's spiritual void
and recognizes that the clean
well-lighted bar represents a
sanctuary to this alcoholic
customer who believes in nothing.
The story concludes with
the old waiter reciting
"The Lord's Prayer" to himself.
But he substitutes the Spanish word
"nada" for every significant word.
In Hemingway's story, "The Lord's
Prayer" becomes the following.
"Our nada who art the
nada, nada be thy name,
thy kingdom nada, thy
will be nada, nada.
God in heaven had become nothing.
Hemingway adopts Unamuno's agnostic
refrain "nada" for his short story
and incorporates the word
"nada" into "The Lord's Prayer."
So when the Spanish Civil War
began Hemingway already knew
about Unamuno, and Hemingway
adopted Unamuno's attitude
that Fascism was the
enemy of culture.
Fascism was an exercise in nihilism.
The Fascist refrain was not "nada,"
but something even
more existential --
"viva la muerte," long live death.
Another Spanish poet,
Antonio Machado,
also believed that Fascism
was the enemy of culture.
Antonio Machado wrote the
following at the outset
of the Spanish Civil War.
So here's a fairly long passage
of a paragraph by Antonio Machado.
"Fascism is the force
of anti-culture,
the negation of the spirit.
The people protect works of art with
devotion and Fascism destroys them
with rage because they are
works of spirit and culture.
I affirm that absolutely the Prada
Museum, the National Library,
have been bombarded without
any military objective other
than the fatal necessity of
destruction which motivates Fascism.
I have seen the marks of the shells
used on those temples of culture.
Cultural interests are in danger.
This vandal bombardment shows it.
Culture is a military
objective for the Fascists.
And to destroy culture they
send their foreign airplanes
as ambassadors of the
negative forces of history."
That's the end of the
quote of Machado.
So when Hemingway went to Spain
during the Spanish Civil war he
recognized immediately the
attitude of Unamuno and Machado,
who considered Fascism a threat
to culture and civilization.
In fact, Hemingway became a close
ally of a group of Spanish writers
who called themselves "The Alliance
of Antifascist Intellectuals
for the Defense of Culture," which
was founded the year the war began.
The Spanish poet, Raphael Alberti,
was the Director of The Alliance.
The Alliance was an
official organization
under the Spanish Republic's
Ministry of Public Education.
In other words, The
Alliance was created
to produce propaganda
favorable to the Republic.
Much of their propaganda depicted
Fascists destroying culture.
Hemingway contributed to
this propaganda effort
by writing For Whom the
Bell Tolls as a homage
to Raphael Alberti and The Alliance.
Hemingway's classic novel
of the Spanish Civil War is
really a tribute to the history
of Spain and to Hispanic culture.
In fact, Hemingway includes the
etymology of the word "Espania"
in the middle of his novel.
On the first page of Chapter Three
of For Whom the Bell Tolls
Hemingway offers his etymological
study of the word "Espania."
This etymological study is cryptic
and requires careful
scrutiny of the text.
It is not nearly as obvious as
Hemingway's use of the Spanish word
"nada" in the short
story we just discussed.
The word "Espania," the Spanish
word for Spain is derived
from the Latin word
"Hispania" with an "H."
Obviously "Hispania" is the root
word of the adjective "Hispanic."
And we are here to celebrate
our Hispanic heritage.
But let's recall that Hispania
was the name given to Spain
by the Romans when they
conquered the Iberian Peninsula.
Hispania was an integral
part of the Roman Empire
and three Roman Emperors were
from Hispania, namely Trajan,
Hadrian, and Marcus Aurelius.
Before the Romans conquered Spain,
the Greeks had established
colonies in Iberia.
But the earliest immigrants to Spain
were the Phoenicians who sailed
to Spain over 3000 years ago.
Phoenicia is now Lebanon at the
eastern end of the Mediterranean,
while Spain is at the western
end of the Mediterranean.
Therefore, when the Phoenicians
sailed to Spain in 1100 B.C.,
they called Spain Span, S-P-A-N,
because Span was the
Phoenician word for hidden.
For the Phoenicians,
Spain was the hidden land
at the other end of
the Mediterranean.
Hemingway knew this and
he originally planned
to entitle his novel,
The Undiscovered Country before
settling upon For Whom the Bell
Tolls .
The Undiscovered Country
sounds like the Phoenician name
for Spain, the hidden land.
We should notice also
that the word, "Hispanic,"
and also the Spanish word "Espania"
both include the Phoenician root
word "Span."
The four letters, S-P-A-N, still
figure prominently in both words,
"Espania," and "Hispanic."
It easy to trace the etymology of
"Espania" back to the Latin name
"Hispania" with an H. After all,
Spanish is a romance language.
But the Romans maintained
the Phoenician word "Span"
within their name, "Hispania."
But the Phoenician name for Spain,
Span, also had another meaning.
Besides meaning hidden,
Span means "rabbit."
So for the Phoenicians, Spain
was the land of the rabbit.
Rabbits proliferated in Spain, so
Spain was the land of the rabbit.
Everybody knows that in For Whom
the Bell Tolls the protagonist
Robert Jordan has a distinctive
nickname for his lover, Maria.
Throughout the novel he calls his
lover "Rabbit" or "Little Rabbit."
In the novel, Robert Jordan is
an American Professor of Spanish
at the University of Montana.
So when he calls Maria "Rabbit"
he is making her a personification
of Spain.
Because he is a professor of
Spanish he knows that the etymology
of the word "Espania"
means land of the rabbit.
Maria is always described in
comparison to the Spanish landscape.
Her hair is compared to a field of
wheat and her breasts are hills.
When Robert Jordan and Maria
make love, the question is asked,
"Did you feel the Earth move?"
Of course this metaphor for a sexual
climax has inspired countless jokes.
However, Hemingway
wanted to make it clear
that Maria is a personification
of the country Spain,
so this is why he compared making
love to Maria with an earthquake.
The joke is obvious,
but not everyone recognizes
the literary intention
to make Maria a symbol of Spain.
Robert Jordan is a Professor
of Spanish so his love
for Maria symbolizes
his love for Spain.
Like Hemingway, Robert
Jordan is concerned
that the Spanish Civil War
will destroy Hispanic culture.
All readers know that the plot
of For Whom the Bell Tolls
is remarkably simple.
The protagonist, Robert Jordan,
carries a knapsack full of dynamite
which he plans to use
to blow up a bridge.
By exploding the bridge
he can prevent the enemy
from advancing toward Spain.
Not surprisingly, Hemingway
transformed the --
transforms the bridge into
another important symbol.
After all, that is the
essence of literature.
Hemingway's metaphorical method
becomes apparent early in the novel
on the first page of Chapter Three
of For Whom the Bell Tolls .
The Professor, Robert
Jordan, examines the bridge
that he wants to blow up.
He examines the structure of the
bridge carefully because he wants
to place the dynamite strategically.
He even carries a notepad and
draws diagrams of the bridge.
This seems like an odd pursuit
for a Professor of Spanish
who is accustomed to
conjugating verbs rather
than drawing diagrams of bridges.
However, both pursuits, the
grammatical and the architectural,
demand the same power of analysis.
Robert Jordan even says to himself,
"You're a bridge blower
now, not a thinker."
As he diagrams the
bridge and ruminates,
Robert Jordan uses the word
"span" as a synonym for bridge.
In fact, Hemingway uses the noun
"span" or the past-tense verb form
"spanned" three times on
Page One of Chapter Three
as Robert Jordan draws the bridge.
Following are the three sentences
on the first page of Chapter Three
of For Whom the Bell Tolls that
include the word "span" or "spanned"
in reference to the bridge.
So here's a quote from the novel.
"It was a steel bridge
of a single span
and there was a sentry at each box.
It was wide enough for
two motors cars to pass
and it spanned a deep gorge.
Now he was noting the points where
the explosive should be placed
in order to cut the
support of the span
and drop a section
of it in the gorge."
As we have seen, span is the
Phoenician word for "Spain."
Who else would know this other
than a Professor of Spanish?
When Robert Jordan
calls Maria "Rabbit,
and when he calls the bridge a span,
he is demonstrating his knowledge
of the etymology of
the word "Espania."
Maria personifies Spain and the
bridge is another symbol of Spain.
Many people have wandered the
mountains northwest of Madrid,
the Sierra de Guadarrama,
looking for a bridge
resembling the one described
by Robert Jordan in the novel.
Needless to say they have
never found the bridge,
so they criticize Hemingway
for lack of verisimilitude.
These are the same
people, of course,
who laugh at the lovers
who make the Earth move.
Hemingway's novel is not
a historical chronicle
of the Spanish Civil War.
On the contrary, For Whom
the Bell Tolls is an allegory
and in an allegory all characters
and things represent
as abstract ideas.
Maria and the bridge are symbols
of Spain, which raises the question,
what does Robert Jordan represent?
His last name is the same as that
of a famous river, the Jordan River.
Late in the novel the character
makes the connection explicitly
between his name and the river.
The Jordan River separates Moses
and the Hebrews from
the Promised Land.
Likewise, in Hemingway's novel,
Robert Jordan must destroy
the bridge over a river
to protect the promised land
of Madrid and all of Spain
from the advance of the enemy.
So why did Hemingway decide to
write his long novel as an allegory
in which one character
personifies Spain
and another character
personifies a river?
The answer requires us here
to introduce another famous Spanish
writer, the poet, Raphael Alberti.
Besides Federico Garcia Lorca,
Raphael Alberti is the most famous
Spanish poet of the 20th century.
Alberti won Spain's National Prize
for a volume of poetry in 1924.
Alberti was a Communist and a
supporter of the Spanish Republic.
During the Spanish Civil War the
poet, Raphael Alberti, and his wife,
Maria Teresa Leon, were two of
the leaders of a group called
"The Alliance of Anti-Fascist
Intellectuals
for the Defense of Culture."
The Alliance was formed in 1936
and became the Spanish Republic's
propaganda mission during the
Spanish Civil War.
The Alliance staged many plays,
and these theatrical productions
influenced Hemingway's composition
of For Whom the Bell Tolls .
Alberti introduced Hemingway to the
Spanish Republic's propaganda war
and Hemingway adopted the Spanish
Republic's posture as the guardian
of Spanish art and culture.
The Alliance performed its plays
in the Zarzuela Theater
in the center of Madrid.
They designed their plays to
encourage the besieged citizens
of Madrid during the
Spanish Civil War.
The most famous play performed
by The Alliance was the
play entitled Numancia .
The play Numancia was written
originally by Cervantes in 1585.
Alberti revised Numancia for
performance during the Spanish
Civil War.
Following is the story
of Numancia .
The Romans ruled Spain from 200 B.C.
to 400 A.D. and fought many wars
against the native Iberians.
The most famous such battle was
fought at Numancia, the Iberian city
to which the Romans
set siege for 16 years.
Numancia is situated on top of
the hill near the modern city
of Soria [assumed spelling] on the
Dwerel [assumed spelling] River.
When the Romans finally
defeated Numancia in 133 B.C.,
they entered the city to
find all the citizens dead
as result of a suicide pact.
The citizens of Numancia
preferred to die instead
of surrendering to the Romans.
Since then, the indomitable
spirit of the Iberians
of Numancia has been
symbolic of Spain's refusal
to surrender to invaders.
The story of Numancia is invoked
whenever Spain is under siege.
The play about Numancia is an
allegory and includes a character
who is a personification of Spain.
This character's name is Hispania.
Another character in the play is a
personification of the Dwerel River,
the river that flows
past Soria and Numancia.
This is where Hemingway got the idea
to write For Whom the
Bell Tolls as an allegory.
Like the characters in
Numancia, the characters
in For Whom the Bell
Tolls are allegorical.
Maria personifies Spain, and Robert
Jordan personifies the Jordan River.
Besides the two allegorical
characters, there's another feature
of For Whom the Bell Tolls that
makes it similar to Numancia.
Both works are about
a siege on a hilltop.
Numancia is about a siege
during which the Iberians
on a hill resist the
Romans for 16 years.
Likewise, Hemingway's characters in
For Whom the Bell Tolls are on top
of the mountain waiting
for the enemy to approach
for the entire duration
of this 500-page novel.
For Whom the Bell
Tolls is designed
to resemble the siege of Numancia.
After all, the only dramatic action
in the entire novel is the
explosion of the bridge.
Other than that the characters
just wait, biding their time on top
of the Guadarrama Mountain
outside of Madrid.
Hemingway's mountain setting and
stalemate resemble the 16-year siege
of the hilltop city of
Numancia by the Romans
in the Second Century B.C.
Besides the play by Cervantes
about Numancia, The Alliance staged
other plays from the Golden Age,
Spain's glorious era of
theater during the Renaissance.
Alberti and Leon had a predilection
for plays with a democratic theme.
The Alliance's strategy was to
dramatize the socialist spirit
with which the Spanish people
have always resisted the tyranny
of kings in the past.
The same tyranny embodied by Franco
during the Spanish Civil War.
Besides Numancia, Lope de Vega's
play entitled Fuenteovejuna formed
part of The Alliance's repertoire.
In this classic Spanish play,
published in the year 1619,
the citizens of the town
of Fuenteovejuna killed the
tyrannical [foreign word].
When the judge interrogates
individual citizens each one
responds by saying that
Fuenteovejuna is the culprit.
In other words, when they are
asked to identify the killer,
they say the whole town did it.
By offering the same response, the
citizens forfeit their individuality
to protect themselves
in a collective identity
which is the essence of socialism.
Hemingway even mentions the title
of the play, Fuenteovejuna ,
within the pages of For
Whom the Bell Tolls .
Lope de Vega's name also
appears in the novel.
Hemingway's allusion to Lope
de Vega is really a homage
to Alberti and The Alliance.
Furthermore, Chapter 10 of For
Whom the Bell Tolls represents
Hemingway's version
of Fuenteovejuna .
Many readers sympathetic
to the Spanish Republic
have criticized Hemingway
for including Chapter
10 in his novel
because the scene narrates a
wild frenzied massacre during
which the Republicans kill Fascists
in a ritual ceremonial fashion.
However, it is wrong to way
that Hemingway is criticizing
the Republican in this scene.
On the contrary, the
point of the massacre is
to show the socialist
spirit of the Republic.
Hemingway does not want
to emphasize the violence
but rather the cooperative
communal spirit of the ceremony.
The key to understanding this
scene is the mutual desire
of the townspeople to share
the blame amongst themselves.
Each citizen is obliged
to participate
in the lynching of the Fascists.
Like Lope de Vega, Hemingway
wants to portray mass identity
as the fundamental
element of socialism.
The citizens protect themselves
by not allowing individuality
when they must pass judgment
on the fate of the tyrant.
During the massacre one of
Hemingway's characters even says,
"Each man should have his
share in the responsibility."
The character named Pilar says, "If
the Fascists were to be executed
by the people, it was better for
all the people to have a part in it,
and I wish to share the
guilt as much as any."
Hemingway's line recalls the most
famous line in Fuenteovejuna .
When officials investigate
the killing,
all the citizens respond,
"Fuenteovejuna did it."
Both Lope de Vega and
Hemingway create scenes
in which citizens protect each
other by assuming a mass identity,
or rather a socialist identity,
so no individual can be
singled out for responsibility.
This explains Hemingway's direct
reference to a 17th century play
in his 20th century novels.
Another favorite play performed
by The Alliance was The Mayor
of Zalamea , a play written
by Pedro Calderon de la
Barca in the year 1636.
This play also portrays the Spanish
people's resistance to tyranny.
In Calderon's play, the Spanish
Army is courted in the town
of Zalamea on its way to Portugal.
A captain in the army rapes the
daughter of the Mayor of Zalamea
who in turn executes the captain.
The King of Spain arrives in
Zalamea and determines that,
while the mayor has no
jurisdiction over the army,
his execution of the
captain is just.
Calderon's play is about the
democratic right of Spanish citizens
to resist abuse by the Spanish
Army even under a monarchy.
Hemingway offers his version of
The Mayor of Zalamea in Chapter 31
of For Whom the Bell Tolls .
In this chapter, Hemingway narrates
how the Fascists rape the daughter
of the mayor of a Spanish town.
This is a clear allusion to
the plot of Calderon's play.
Both Calderon's play and
Hemingway's novel depict the rape
of a mayor daughter.
In Hemingway's novel,
Maria's father is the mayor
of the town where he is killed.
So his assassination
acquires symbolic value.
His assassins take his
daughter, Maria, into his office
in the city hall and rape her there,
thus augmenting the symbolic
nature of the action.
Besides assaulting
Maria as an individual,
the Fascists are expressing scorn
for the civil authorities
in the Republic.
In summary, the central plot of
For Whom the Bell Tolls resembles
that of Numancia , a
play written by Cervantes
and revised by Raphael Alberti.
Chapter 10 of For Whom
the Bell Tolls is a homage
to Lope de Vega's play
entitled Fuenteovejuna ,
a play mentioned directly
in Hemingway's novel.
Chapter 31 of Hemingway's
novel is a homage
to Calderon's play entitled
The Mayor of Zalamea .
These three plays from Spain's
Golden Age of Theater formed part
of the repertoire of The
Alliance directed by Alberti
and Leon during the
Spanish Civil War.
The purpose of The Alliance
was to encourage democracy
by preserving Spain's
democratic heritage portrayed
in Golden Age plays.
The Alliance organized a group
of actors called Guerreras
[assumed spelling] del Teatro
which staged plays at the front to
encourage the Republican soldiers.
By calling themselves Guerreras,
these actors underscored
the close relationship
between theater and warfare.
The Guerreras del Teatro
imagined themselves as soldier
in the propaganda war, and
The Alliance was their army.
When Hemingway wrote For Whom
the Bell Tolls he aligned himself
with The Alliance and
its propaganda machine.
And Hemingway became yet
another Guerrera del Teatro.
Toward the end of For Whom the Bell
Tolls the character Pilar says,
"So much theater tires me."
When she speaks the word
"theater" she is referring to war
which she compares to theater.
But besides the metaphor, Hemingway
also wants the reader to recognize
that Pilar is an actor in a play.
She is a Guerrera del
Teatro and when she speaks
of theater she is saying
that the plot
of Hemingway's novel is also the
plot of the play Numancia .
Pilar's statement demands that the
reader ask if he's reading a novel
about the Spanish Civil War or
if he is watching a presentation
of a play performed by The Alliance.
The reader must recall that
Hemingway wrote only one play
in his life, and that play is
about the Spanish Civil War.
The Fifth Column is Hemingway's
play about the siege of Madrid
and it was intended as a homage
to the theatrical presentations
of The Alliance and the
Guerreras del Teatro.
The artistic and political
affinity between Hemingway
and Alberti continued beyond
the Spanish Civil War.
Both men were exiled from
Spain at war's end in 1939.
Hemingway went to Cuba and
Alberti went to Argentina.
However, they did not
concede defeat.
They still had hope that the
Spanish Republic would be revived
to replace Franco's
dictatorship in Spain.
Hemingway maintained
the indomitable spirit
of Numancia and The Alliance
from his exile in Cuba.
In fact, the Spanish
Republic's fight against Fascism
in Spain motivated the revolution
in Cuba, which triumphed in 1959.
The influence of Alberti
can even be seen
in Hemingway's novel entitled
The Old Man and the Sea .
Published in 1952, 12
years after the publication
of For Whom the Bell Tolls .
The Old Man and the Sea is
about a simple Cuban
fisherman named Santiago.
In The Old Man and the Sea
Hemingway alludes to a poem
by Alberti as a way of
saying that the spirit
of The Alliance now lives in Cuba.
Hemingway alludes directly
to a famous poem by Alberti
in the following passage from
The Old Man and the Sea .
Here's a quote from The
Old Man and the Sea .
"He always thought of the sea as la
mar, which is what people call her
in Spanish when they love her
as though she were a woman.
Some of the younger
fishermen spoke of her
as el mar, which is masculine."
In this passage, as in his other
works about Spain and Cuba,
Hemingway leaves some words in
Spanish to invoke Hispanic culture.
We have already discussed A
Clean Well-Lighted Place in
which Hemingway repeats the
Spanish word "nada," repeatedly.
In the above passage from
The Old Man and the Sea ,
Hemingway suggests that
"mar," the Spanish word
for "sea" can be preceded
by either the feminine
or masculine definite
article, "la" or "el."
Hemingway's reason for
distinguishing between "la mar"
and "el mar" is found in
the first line of a poem
of the first anthology
published by Raphael Alberti.
So here's a quote from
a poem by Alberti.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Thus begins a poem
of [foreign words],
the anthology that began
Alberti's poetic career in 1924.
[Foreign words], the
translated title,
I believe, is "Land-Locked Sailor."
Alberti won Spain's National Prize
for this volume, so
it was well-known.
When Hemingway explains the
difference between "el mar"
and " la mar" in Spanish in the
middle of an English language book,
he is paying homage to
the first famous poem
by his friend Raphael
Alberti, 13 years after the end
of the Spanish Civil War.
Another passage in The Old Man and
the Sea represents a paraphrase
of another poem by Alberti.
Like all of Hemingway's
books, The Old Man
and the Sea has a
very simple plot.
The old Cuban fisherman named
Santiago hooks a giant fish
and then spends the whole
novel pulling him in.
In the middle of the book,
the old fisherman recalls his
youth to give him strength.
Specifically, he recalls
the time he participated
in an arm-wrestling match.
Here's another quote from
The Old Man and the Sea .
"As the sun set, he remembered
to give himself confidence,
the time in the tavern at Casablanca
when he had played the hand game
with the great negro from Cienfuegos
who is the strongest
man on the dock."
That's the end of the
quote from the [inaudible].
The arm-wrestling match lasts
all night and ends in a draw.
As Santiago struggles with his fish,
his mind wanders back to his youth.
His recollection of the
arm-wrestling match represents a way
of summoning strength,
the strength of his youth.
Nonetheless, this interpellated
tale requires further justification,
and Raphael Alberti's poetry
again provides an explanation.
In 1935, Alberti wrote a volume
of poetry entitled [speaking
in foreign language].
In other words, "Thirteen
Stripes and 48 Stars."
The anthology's title
refers to the American flag.
And the poems within are
about American imperialism
in Latin America.
The fourth poem in the collection
is entitled [foreign words].
The first stanza of [foreign
words] is as follows.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
In English, these lines
are as follows.
"Black man, give your
hand to the white man.
White man, give your
hand to the black man.
Hand to hand, for Cuba does
not belong to the Cuban,
but rather to the American."
[Foreign words] is an allegory
of American imperialism in Cuba.
The black man personifies Cuba
while the white man personifies the
United States.
As the arm wrestle mano o mano,
they determine the
political fate of Cuba.
In The Old Man and the Sea
Santiago recalls an arm-wrestling
match in which he competes with
a black man from [foreign words].
Santiago's memory
of the arm-wrestling match is quite
singular because it has nothing
to do with the story's plot.
His recollection is even more
distinctive because he stipulates
that his opponent is black
while Santiago himself is white.
The memory lasts two
full pages in the middle
of The Old Man and the Sea .
Santiago's gratuitous memory
of the arm-wrestling match
is Hemingway's homage
to Alberti's poem [foreign words].
The scene in Hemingway's novel
and Alberti's poem share a
common setting, a common action,
and a common cast of characters.
In both cases the setting is
Cuba, the action is arm-wrestling,
and the characters are a
white man and a black man
in competition against each other.
The reader must ask why Hemingway
would allude to Alberti's poem
about American imperialism in Cuba.
When Alberti published the poem in
1935, Fulgencio Batista had been
in power in Cuba for two years, and
would remain in power until 1944
when he left Cuba for Florida.
Batista returned to
power in Cuba in 1952,
the same year that Hemingway
published The Old Man
and the Sea .
By referring to Alberti's poem
in The Old Man and the Sea ,
Hemingway is acknowledging
that the United States
and Cuba were wrestling for
the fate of Cuba in 1952.
Batista was an American puppet
who forfeited the interests
of common Cubans like
Santiago to make concessions
to American businesses in Cuba.
Hemingway's protagonist
is a humble fisherman
who lives on the day's catch.
The Cuban economy in 1952 has
become distorted to the extent
that life is almost impossible for
the subsistence fisherman Santiago
who must play the lottery
for financial survival.
The final stanza of [foreign words]
reinforces the allegorical quality
of the arm-wrestling match --
mano o mano [speaking in foreign
language] norteamericano, negro,
mano o mano, blanco, mano o mano,
negri [assumed spelling] blanco,
mano o mano, mano o
mano, mano o mano.
For the better part of this stanza
Alberti simply repeats the words
"mano o mano" which
literally mean "hand to hand"
and which have become
recognizable to English speakers.
Alberti is saying that
Cuba is engaged constantly
in an arm-wrestling match
against the American.
Hemingway's arm-wrestling
scene in The Old Man
and the Sea is memorable.
But one must be aware of Hemingway's
political and artistic affinity
with Alberti to recognize
that Santiago's arm-wrestling
match represents his struggle
with American imperialism.
Hemingway and Alberti
both supported the side
that lost the Spanish Civil
War against Fascism in 1939.
When he wrote The Old
Man and the Sea in 1952,
Hemingway was attempting to sustain
the anti-imperialist spirit in Cuba
where many Spanish Republicans
went after the Spanish Civil War.
If you go to Havana, you
can visit the hotel room
where Hemingway wrote For
Whom the Bell Tolls .
Room 511 of the Ambos-Mundos
Hotel is now a museum dedicated
to Hemingway.
You can look out the
window at Havana Bay
and imagine Hemingway
writing his novel about Spain,
a country from which he
was exiled for 14 years
after the Spain and Civil War.
When Hemingway was in Cuba,
he was homesick for Spain.
The most nostalgic scene
in For Whom the Bell
Tolls is about Valencia.
One of the characters recalls going
to the bullfight there during
the big fiesta in July.
Then the character recalls eating
paella outdoors on the beach.
This scene is remarkable
for the menu
as Hemingway recalls eating
seafood and cold melon.
He recalls drinking beer
and wine in Valencia.
It is a very sensual scene,
a bombardment of tastes
which ends inevitably in the bedroom
with two characters making love.
This beautiful scene
is Hemingway's farewell
to Spain written in
a Cuban hotel room.
We must ask why Hemingway
chose Valencia as the site
of this nostalgic farewell to Spain.
The answer is clear.
Hemingway began writing The Sun
Also Rises in Valencia in 1925.
Of course, The Sun Also Rises
was Hemingway's first masterpiece
about Spain.
In The Sun Also Rises , the
characters run with the bulls
through the streets of Pamplona.
Hemingway attended the
big bullfight fiesta
in Pamplona early in July, 1925.
And then he followed the
bullfighters to Valencia
for the season's next big fiesta
which takes place every
year in late July.
Fourteen years later,
Hemingway was in Cuba trying
to write his second novel about
Spain, For Whom the Bell Tolls .
For inspiration Hemingway
invokes the memory of Valencia
where the muses had blessed
him with The Sun Also Rises .
Let us imagine that we
are in Valencia and 1925
as Hemingway writes
The Sun Also Rises .
In Valencia, in 1925, Hemingway
surely was inspired by the legacy
of the Spanish writer
Vicente Blasco Ibanez.
Vicente Blasco Ibanez was the
pride of Valencia and the author
of international best sellers.
One of the most famous novels
by Blasco Ibanez is
about the bullfight.
That novel is entitled
Blood and Sand ,
published in Spanish in 1908.
The American public became familiar
with Blood and Sand in 1922
when Hollywood produced
a film version
of the novel starring
Rudolph Valentino.
Rudolph Valentino was
Hollywood's first super star.
In fact, the first
iconic Hollywood portrait
of the romantic male lead
was Rudolph Valentino dressed
as a bullfighter in 1922.
When Hemingway published
The Sun Also Rises in 1926,
the American public
still recalled the image
of Rudolph Valentino
dressed as a bullfighter
in the film version
of Blood and Sand .
Hollywood and Blasco Ibanez
prepared the American public
for Hemingway's bullfight
novel of 1926.
Certain characteristics
of Hemingway's novel show a
clear debt to Blood and Sand .
The Spanish novel by Blasco Ibanez
includes a female character named
Dona Sol who is a classic femme
fatale who seduces a bullfighter
and sabotages his career.
Anyone who has read Hemingway's
The Sun Also Rises knows
that the female protagonist Brett
Ashley seduces the bullfighter Pedro
Romero and jeopardizes his
performance in the bullring.
In 1924, Hemingway published
a one-page experimental piece
in the Parisian edition of In Our
Time that describes the bullfight
in cinematic terms.
Hemingway describes a bullfighter
who dies in the bullring
after he is gored by
the horn of the bull.
Part of the piece reads as follows.
"[Foreign word] felt everything
getting larger and larger
and then smaller and smaller.
Then it got larger and larger and
larger, then smaller and smaller.
Then everything commenced
to run faster and faster,
as when they speed up
a cinematograph film.
Then he was dead."
In this passage Hemingway
uses two cinematic techniques.
He describes those -- a zoom lens
as the scene gets larger and larger
and then smaller and smaller.
The second technique is
Hemingway's appeal to fast motion
as when they speed up the camera.
Why would Hemingway write
about the view of the bullfight
through the lens of a movie camera?
The clear answer is
that Hemingway is trying
to appease the American reader who
already associates the bullfight
with the famous film
starring Rudolph Valentino
which was released only two years
before Hemingway's publication.
Even before Blood and Sand ,
Hemingway had already been
influenced by another novel
by Vicente Blasco Ibanez.
That novel was about the First
World War, and it was entitled,
The Four Horsemen
of the Apocalypse .
"The Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
was published in Spain in Spanish
in 1916, and it was the first
great novel of the First World War.
A hundred years later,
the two best-known novels
about the First World War are
Hemingway's IT A Farewell to Arms
and Remarque's All Quiet
on the Western Front .
However, both of those novels
were published in 1929,
13 years after Blasco Ibanez's
masterpiece and 10 full years
after the end of the war.
We cannot underestimate
the influence
of The Four Horsemen
of the Apocalypse .
In 1919, the English
language translation
of this Spanish novel
was the bestselling novel
in the United States.
In fact, the Spanish novel
was so popular in America,
it was made into a
Hollywood film in 1921.
The star of that film, yet
again, was Rudolph Valentino.
The very next year in 1922
Valentino starred in Blood
and Sand which we've
just discussed.
Between the years 1919 and 1922,
Vicente Blasco Ibanez
became enormously popular
in the United States
because of his novels
about the bullfight and
the First World War.
Blasco Ibanez made a lecture tour
of the United States in 1919,
and he was featured in
"Life Magazine" in 1920.
His name and image were
everywhere and his novels were made
into films starring
Rudolph Valentino.
The Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse , the best-selling novel
of 1919 takes its title from
the last book of the Bible,
the Book of Revelation, also
known as the Apocalypse.
The Book of Revelation includes many
symbolic characters including the
four horsemen who represent
pestilence, war, famine, and death.
The First World War
was so cataclysmic
that many people though doomsday
was near, so the biblical reference
to the apocalypse comprised
a suitable title
for a novel about the war.
The influence of Blasco Ibanez
on popular American culture
became most apparent in 1924
when the backfield of the University
of Notre Dame football team
was named the Four Horsemen
by the most famous sportswriter in
American history, Grantland Rice.
Everyone in the United States
recognized the connection
between Rudolph Valentino and
the Notre Dame football team.
Also in 1924, the same year that
the Four Horsemen played football
for Notre Dame, Hemingway
published his first fictional pieces
about the First World War.
And like the Notre
Dame football team,
Hemingway was influenced
by Blasco Ibanez.
For example, in 1925, Hemingway
published a short story entitled
"On the Quay at Smyrna."
The story is barely two pages long
and began as a newspaper article
that Hemingway wrote
for the Toronto Star .
While living in Paris after World
War I, Hemingway went to Turkey
to cover the conflict between
Greece and Turkey in 1922.
The First World War was over
but skirmishes continued
and Hemingway found symbolic
value in this incident
in which the Turkish army
drove Greek residents
from the coast city of Smyrna.
"On the Quay at Smyrna"
cannot be any shorter.
However, the entire
story is in the title.
Where is Smyrna?
What is the importance of Smyrna?
Smyrna is on the western
coast of Turkey.
But Smyrna is also mentioned
in the Book of Revelation,
the last book of the Bible
that inspired the title
of the novel by Blasco Ibanez.
John the Divine wrote the Book of
Revelation on the island of Patmos,
and sent it as a letter
to seven churches
in Asia Minor, now called Turkey.
One of the seven churches to which
John sent his letter is the Church
at Smyrna.
In other words, Hemingway
knew that the mere mention
of Smyrna would conjure
up apocalyptic images
of doom among those readers
familiar with the Bible.
As a result, Hemingway does
not have to write a long story
about the apocalypse
because the title says it all
in a cryptic illusive style
that would become the hallmark
of Hemingway's entire career.
This shortest of short
stories, published in 1925,
is evidence of Hemingway's debt to
Blasco Ibanez whose famous novel,
The Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
, already had made the connection
between the Book of Revelation
and the First World War.
In the Book of Revelation, Jesus
says, "I am the alpha and the omega,
the beginning and the end,
the first and the last."
Hemingway's story quotes
these words but reverses them.
Hemingway says, "No end and
no beginning," as if to say
that all history has ended.
Furthermore, Smyrna is
near the remains of Troy,
so Hemingway suggests
that the Greco-Turkish War
of 1922 was reminiscent of the
Trojan War, with references
to the Bible and to Homer's
Iliad , Hemingway suggests
that there has only
been one war in history.
It just never stopped, and it
will end only with the apocalypse.
When Hemingway won the Noble
Prize in 1954 he said he was happy
to be the first Cuban writer to
win the Nobel Prize for Literature.
He said this in Spanish during an
interview on Cuban television just
after he received the award.
Even Hemingway considered
himself a Cuban writer.
Six years later in 1960
Hemingway was forced
to leave his beloved Cuban
home because of politics.
Hemingway decided to move
in Idaho where he would live
for only one year before
committing suicide.
The choice of Idaho is significant
because Idaho had a
high concentration
of Basque immigrants from Spain.
Traditionally, Basques migrated to
the American West, to Idaho, Nevada,
and new Mexico where they
would work as shepherds.
After working for 15 or
20 years they would return
to the Basque country where
they could retire comfortably
with their American fortune.
The Basque shepherds in Idaho
reminded Hemingway of his youth
in Spain when he wrote
about the bullfight.
During Hemingway's last
year in Idaho he was visited
by a Spanish novelist, Jose Luis
Castillo Puche, who wrote a novel
about his visit to Idaho.
The novel is entitled, Oro
Blanco or White Gold ,
a reference to the
lucrative wool industry
and employed the Basque immigrants.
Jose Luis Castillo Puche later
wrote the most famous book
in Spanish about Hemingway.
When Hemingway committed
suicide on July 2nd, 1961,
he already had tickets to
the bullfights in Pamplona
which were scheduled to begin
five days later on July 7th,
just as they do every year.
His suicide occurred only
three months after the Bay
of Pigs invasion of Cuba which
took place in April, 1961.
Hemingway knew he would
never be able to return
to his beautiful home in Cuba.
One year after his
suicide, in July, 1962,
some Cuban fishermen erected a
bust of Hemingway in the village
of Kohima, the setting of
The Old Man and the Sea .
Just three months after
they erected the bust,
the Cuban Missile Crisis
transpired between America
and the Soviet Union
in October, 1962.
Even on the eve of the Cuban Missile
Crisis, the citizens of Cuba knew
that Hemingway loved them.
In 1968, even Franco allowed
the citizens of Pamplona,
Spain to erect a bust of Hemingway,
whose books had been censored
as Communist propaganda
by the same regime.
These busts of Hemingway were
erected by a Communist regime
in Cuba and by a Fascist
regime in Spain.
Hemingway's books are transcendent
because they unite cultures
that have been separated
by politicians.
These two busts of Hemingway
are the best evidence
that literature is the best
diplomacy and that a novel
by Hemingway is the best
passport to Spain and Cuba.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Francisco Madias:
Thank you very much.
>> Douglas LaPrade.
Thank you.
>> Francisco Madias: We have
just a few moments of --
if there are any burning questions
for Dr. LaPrade, we
could take those now.
Yes.
>> I'm curious about translations.
Were any of the works [inaudible]
translated into English?
Were they well-known
in this country?
>> Douglas LaPrade:
Not at that time, no.
Unamuno wrote something
about Walt Whitman.
You know, they're -- so if you want
to begin to talk about that sort
of dialog it begins that early.
But I'm not aware of any
translation that early of --
certainly in [foreign words]
but not Unamuno either, yeah.
>> So many were --
any way [inaudible].
>> Douglas LaPrade: He did one?
>> Yeah.
>> Douglas LaPrade: Yes, he did.
In fact, I'll tell you now.
I spent the summer in Spain.
And one of the last
names I just mentioned --
there was Jose Luis Castillo
Puche, the Spanish novelist.
He won Spain's National Prize
in 1958 and again in 1982.
He's probably 20 years
younger than Hemingway.
He was born in 1919.
They were friends.
And I'm on his foundation.
I spent the summer in his archives
looking for letters from Hemingway.
And, yes, they are in Spanish.
That's later, of course.
Though they didn't
meet until the '50s.
But he was good with languages.
>> Well, thank you for
doing this presentation.
Extremely interesting,
historically significant.
And I'm glad we're covering it
here at the Library of Congress.
I was just curious of when the
embassy was determining whether
or not to change the term
[inaudible] Fascist to Nationalist.
Was Hemingway ever
consulted during that time
or was it just government
embassy and studios with embassy?
Was the author ever consulted?
>> Douglas LaPrade: The best
story I know about that.
He was involved in the writing of
the script and one thing I thought
about including in the
presentation today --
Hemingway wanted to employ
somebody named Gustavo Duran
as technical consultant
on the script.
It wasn't allowed because if
-- this was, you know, 1943.
It was frankly the early
days of McCarthyism.
Gustavo Duran was a Communist.
And he was a friend of Hemingway's.
But they were aware of the
preparation of the script.
There again, I'll refer to
Jose Luis Castillo Puche.
One time he told me he sat down
with Hemingway and a translation
of the novel and started pointing
out errors in the translation.
Hemingway got angry and threw
the book across the room.
But -- So Hemingway would go
back to Spain in the '50s.
He was aware of the censorship,
but according to what they say,
he was frankly more concerned
about getting his royalties.
So he had become rather
pragmatic at that point.
Yes, sir.
>> So at that time, the '40s,
the '30s and the '40s, the --
certainly by the '50s, didn't
Hemingway start to get a sense
of the genocide that the Communists
had been perpetrating since 1917?
And, you know, when you look at
Stalin in Russia and you talk about,
you know, how they just
annihilated Russian culture.
And, you know, and Red China.
That was much later, but didn't
Hemingway just sort of get a sense
for that and start to pull back?
>> Douglas LaPrade: Yes.
There again, one thing
you can say about --
I don't think you could ever
accuse him of having a party card.
And even the -- the
alter-ego protagonist,
Robert Jordan in the novel, he,
you know, in a sort of stream
of consciousness way asks
himself, "Are you a Communist?"
He says, "No.
But I accepted Communist discipline
for the duration of the war."
That's it.
So he does acknowledge being a
Communist sympathizer in Stalin.
There's one page in the novel
where he mentions the non-Stalinist
or non-Soviet indigenous
Communist Party of Spain, the POUM,
Partit Obrer d'Unificaci Marxista.
If it has the word
Marxist in the title,
it's going to be a Communist Party.
Stalin did come in and
eliminate that party.
And, of course, that's
why it's so difficult
to understand the Spanish Civil War.
It's not left against right.
It's left against left.
That was largely in Barcelona in May
of 1937 at the Place de Catalonia.
There's a Hotel Cologne [assumed
spelling] and the Telefonica
where -- Stalin came in
to eliminate the FAI,
Federacion Anarquista
Iberica, and the POUM.
And Hemingway ridicules the
POUM in the middle of his novel.
That's how you can tell that,
yes, he is a Stalin sympathizer.
And, of course, the best story in
that regard -- about 11 years ago,
it was 2005, a good book came out.
There's a Steven Koch,
K-O-C-H, Cook, Koch -- I'm --
frankly I don't know
how to pronounce it.
It was called The Breaking Point .
And it described Hemingway's
break with Dos Passos.
And, of course, Dos Passos was more
explicitly Communist than Hemingway.
Made tours of the Soviet
Union and so on.
But when his translator, who taught
at Johns Hopkins and was a native
of Valencia, was assassinated
by, or executed by Stalin,
Hemingway told him to dismiss
it as a casualty of war.
And so the title of that books
if The Breaking Point .
And there's a good book in Spanish,
Ignacio Martinez de Pison,
called [foreign words].
So he talks about -- there again,
Hemingway in relation
to Stalinism, sure.
>> Do you know if Hemingway
ever visited the Soviet Union?
>> Douglas LaPrade: I know that he
published something with Pravda.
You know, there's a character
in For Whom the Bell Tolls .
He calls him Karkov.
It's a thinly disguised
name for Koltsov.
Koltsov was the -- a
journalist for Pravda
who was Stalin's right-hand man.
And so I don't believe
Hemingway went.
Here's something else
that's rather interesting.
There's a guy named
Alexander Orloff who record --
in 1935 he was in Cambridge
recruiting the Cambridge spies
who then became the double
agents for the next 40 years.
And in 1936 he goes to Madrid
and sets up the Secret Police,
the precursor to the KGB.
So all through For Whom the
Bell Tolls there's a reference
to the SIM, Servicio de
Investigacion Militar
which is the Secret Police
at the service of Stalin.
Alexander Orloff set all
of that up and he claims
to have taught Hemingway about
guerilla warfare in Benicassim
which is on the Valencia Coast.
He had a training camp
for guerilla warfare.
So Hemingway was close
to these Communists,
the Soviets Koltsov
and Alexander Orlov.
Alexander Orlov --
Koltsov was called back
to Moscow and was killed.
He was part of the purge,
or one of the purges.
And then Alexander Orlov got
recalled and he knew what was going
to happen, so he escaped, went
to Cleveland, lived his life
in Cleveland, and in 1963 published
a handbook of guerilla warfare
at the University of Michigan Press.
And he was probably immune
because he had the identity
of the Cambridge spies.
That was his protection.
So, yes, he flirted with disaster
and danger and what have you,
but there again seemed to avoid
the label more than others.
>> Can I have one other question?
>> Douglas LaPrade: Mm-hmm.
>> Sure. In Hemingway's
short stories,
he talks about his involvement
in the Hispanic Civil War.
It seems he's always
doing propaganda films.
>> Douglas LaPrade: Very good.
>> Did he do -- did he
do any military stuff
with the -- in the revolution?
>> Douglas LaPrade:
I don't think so.
I mean I think you can find a photo
of him reloading a gun for somebody.
But I don't -- in fact, there was
a Republican General, a Communist,
who eventually went to Cuba where
he was more comfortable and --
name of Lister, Enrique
Lister, who was from Galicia.
And the name is Lister.
It sounds English,
but he was Galician.
He's got a book published in
1966 called Nuestra Guerra ,
his memory of -- his memoir
of the Spanish Civil War.
And he ridicules Hemingway frankly
for wanting to go to the front lines
and -- but just being ridiculed
because he wasn't taken
seriously by the combatants.
>> Thank you.
>> Douglas LaPrade: Thank you.
>> Francisco Madias:
Thank you very much
for joining [inaudible]
some Hemingway.
A round of applause.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.